bro what up dog I am so grateful to
witness this moment in history nah this
one take the cake oh congrats
congratulations on becoming the NBA's
all-time leading scorer what a legendary
Night in NBA history my favorite thing
about being a LeBron James fan is just
watching you prove yourself over and
over again Against All Odds and all
doubts it's always fun watching the
Laker get it done this is one of the
greatest accomplishments in sports
history truly an honored to be part of
it as a teammate you changed the game of
basketball it's been an inspiration
since day one you did that and I know
you get a bigger kick out of a great
pass than a score from the time you went
to the league when you had the doubters
and the naysayers and people that think
you wouldn't take it this far prove the
wrong dog you know since you were young
all the goals you set you've
accomplished on and off the court love
you King La Familia for Life
congratulations thank you for wrapping
for all of us keep striving for
greatness always
congratulations King James